well guys I hope you're not afraid of
heights because in this latest episode
of valve has gone [ __ ] crazy cash is
out and vertigo is in now as you can
probably hear I am a little bit sick
today so I do apologize for the raspy
voice but I had to get this hot take to
you right away now last week we released
a video where I was talking about the
increasing frequency of Valve's patching
of csgo and I said at the end of that
video that the next game breaking patch
was just around the corner but there's
one thing I know almost for sure the
next biggest change in csgo history is
probably just around the corner well
this isn't quite at that level but it's
no small potatoes either among various
bug fixes and map changes and some very
nice shiny stickers this latest patch
from valve gave us a very important
change that's going to have
repercussions going forward for the pro
scene and that is of course the easy for
ends music
[Music]
no of course I am talking about vertigo
being in the active duty mat pool and
cache being put into the reserves as
you'd expect the community and pro
reaction is pretty divided some people
are really game to play a game of csgo
on top of a construction site skyscraper
others not so much
the closures that mop why do we play
this much in fact believe it or not a
lot of pros haven't even played this map
or at least haven't played it in many
many years now before we really get into
vertigo I want to say that cash going
out is actually a good thing it's a
great map its classic I know a lot of
you guys love it
but let's be real here it's showing its
age it kind of looks like a but excuse
me I'd like to ask you a few questions
it could really benefit from the kind of
makeovers that dust2 and Inferno were
recently given obviously we're working
with an ancient engine here in terms of
the source engine and there's only so
much we can do with csgo graphics but I
don't know man
dust new and infer new they're like
works of [ __ ] art they look beautiful
so I would love to see that same
treatment be given to cash as well now
when it comes to vertigo personally I
don't really like the map it's way too
cluttered
there's tons of boxes everywhere and
beveled textures and there's just a lot
of [ __ ] stacked on other [ __ ] it's to
visually busy but my opinion and frankly
yours on the map doesn't really matter
does it because we're not map designers
my worry here is that vertigo isn't
quite ready for primetime
we've all seen all of the bugs and
exploits and bad angles and cheesy
strats and wall bangs that have come up
on this map as of late and look I know a
lot of these exploits will be or have
already been patched out of this map but
there are bound to be more and this map
is going to be playable at Dreamhack Rio
later this month and here's my worry are
we going to discover
the next broken wallbang the next unfair
angle in a pro game it was yangko pound
of HT former player former analyst Kurt
basil and coach who tweeted last week
that csgo right now more than ever
represents so many people's livelihood
and making a change like switching out
cash for an untested new sort of
bug-ridden map like vertigo without
maybe thinking it through fully could
affect those livelihoods
now stop yes you stop you who's in the
comment section right now typing their
comment stop it I am NOT saying that
vertigo going into the active duty map
pool is going to put anyone out of work
here I'm simply saying that if we are to
believe that Valve is making significant
changes to the pro scene of their game
at increased frequency without proper
consultation and consideration of all
parties involved that could become a
problem in the future maybe it's time
that valve lifted the veil on these
changes maybe it's time that they
brought in key stakeholders like team
managers coaches analysts the Players
Association even and got them a seat at
the table a voice in these discussions
where valve is thinking of creating
changes that are going to so drastically
affect Pro play now eventually cash we
hope will be coming back looking new and
improved and so will cobblestone
probably even sooner which means some
maps in the current active duty pool
gotta go and even though I just finished
telling you I don't like vertigo very
much personally I hope it sticks around
because slamming it into the active duty
map pool for six months eight months
whatever it be will benefit no one not
the players not the fans not the teams
and certainly not the overall health of
the competitive scene if valve were to
decide to yank this out of the map pool
in those sort of six months eight months
four months whatever it'd be any team or
player that decides to specialize in
this map and actually play it would to
put it plainly get [ __ ] over now the
alternative is if it becomes an unspoken
perma ban in every series and it barely
ever gets played well then what was the
[ __ ] point in the first place the
only option is
valve has to keep vertigo around in the
long-term and they have to be very
responsive and very quick to find bugs
and exploits that will inevitably come
up in the course of Pro play and one
more aside I wanted to have here last
week I sort of half jokingly posited a
conspiracy theory that valve was maybe
trying to nerf ass trolleys here's a
conspiracy theory for you this change
comes about a year at the very least ten
months after a certain Danish team had
been dominating the competitive scene
well obviously this week I got [ __ ]
rekt because they took out the one map
that his Charles doesn't play and one of
liquids the second-best team in the
world's best maps I guess we're in for
six more months one more year two more
years of the starless dominance whatever
I knew that we could do it
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button